اسمحوا لي ان ارحب بالسيد شونيل تجاري
ضيفنا في البعد الاخر لهذا الاسبوع اهلا
بك معنا سيد سونيل وباعتبارك اول من اطلق
صيحه فزع قبل سنوات بشان احتكار خطوط
الانترنت لو تشرح لنا كيف انتبهت الى هذا
الموضوع منذ البدايه
لو نظرنا في التاريخ فان جل الخطوط في
العالم او كلها كانت مملوكه لشركات
الاتصالات لقد كان هناك دائما تعاون بين
الدول المختلفه وبين حكومتها يمكنني القول
انه قبل ثمانيه او عشره اعوام تقريبا بدات
كل من جوجل وميتا تنفقا على هذا الميدان
ثم اطلقت جوجل شبكتها التي تمكنها من
الامتلاك الكامل للخطوط وهذا يضعنا امام
حاله احتكار تشمل كل العالم غالبيه هذه
الخطوط لا تملك الشركات المحليه والحكوميه
اي دور فيها حتى لو مرت عبر اراضيها
وبحارها
ما خطوره ذلك يعني القضيه التي نناقشها هل
هناك امثله عن خطوط وعن تكلفتها غير عن
جوجل
الدكتور
شركات الاربعه الكبرى وخاصه مالكه جوجل
وفيسبوك
الفابيتا هي الملاك الاكبر ومؤخرا انضمت
اليهما امازون ومايكروسوفت بالمشاركه في
هذا الميدان
هل من الممكن عندما يتعلق الامر بالمحيط
الاطلسي هل مازال ممكن نشر كيبل او كوابل
من دون شركات البكتيك اللي تحدثنا عنها
مطلقا لا انه غير ممكن لا يهم فقط كابلات
المحيط والبحار ولكن في كل العالم انشاء
واي خط يتطلب المرور عبر واحده من شركات
البيج تك تك